[Music]
et has learned that Lori Lachlan and
husband Massimo Jian Uli are selling
their lavish bel-air mansion for get
this twenty eight million six hundred
fifty thousand bucks the home is not on
the market just yet but it's quietly
listed for the right buyers the real
estate power play comes amid the
couple's ongoing legal drama surrounding
the College Admission scandal but
interestingly et has learned listing
their house has nothing to do with all
of that Massimo's passion is real estate
he loves architecture and design and
selling their family home is totally
normal for them they typically move
every three to five years still a source
tells ET that everyone seems shocked
they put their house up for sale in the
midst of their legal troubles but our
source maintains quote they've wanted to
sell their home for a long time it is
one step they are taking in attempt to
get back to their normal lives as far as
money goes the source says the family is
not strapped for cash at all in fact
we're told they're doing very well
financially ET has reached out to the
couple for comment on the sale of their
home
news of the Jian Uli family move comes
just two weeks after hundreds of new
documents were released by the US
Attorney's Office shedding more light on
the admission scandal and the couple's
alleged involvement these documents 484
documents that were released both from
Laurie Lachlan as well as her husband
Massimo is absolutely bad news the
fuller house star and her husband are
accused of paying five hundred thousand
dollars in bribes to get their daughters
admitted to USC as recruits for the crew
team even though neither of them has
never participated in the sports the
couple has pleaded not guilty to all
charges presented against them I just
want them to have that experience and
get that education and have a degree to
fall back on as for how Lori and
Massimo's daughter's Bella and Olivia
are doing our source says they're
growing up and want to start fresh
adding that the family is closer than
they've ever been
[Music]